oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview
notre invité cette semaine jean claude
casadesus bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
cette cette invitation merci d'avoir
accepté d'être installé dans un autre
studio que celui dans lequel je suis moi
même les contraintes du coc vide nous
oblige à cette distanciation
c'est pas facile quand même de vivre à
notre époque là aujourd'hui un côté même
si l'intelligence c'est l'adaptation ça
nous pose quand même
alors tout le monde vous connaît
vous êtes un chef d'orchestre star
j'allais dire vous venez de fêter vos 85
ans
c'est extraordinaire vous êtes toujours
en activité avec énormément de projets
on va voir ça dans un instant avec un
disque d'ailleurs un enregistrement
original gustav mahler le chant de la
terre
on va écouter un extrait de cet
enregistrement et vous nous expliquerez
après ce que vous avez voulu faire
[Musique]
alors
je sais pas si vous pouvez nous donner
deux mots de décryptage sur ce que nous
sommes en train d d'écouté pourquoi
avoir choisi cette oeuvre là pour fêter
vos 85 ans dans une actualité qui est
quand même très particulière écoutez
c'est une réflexion très profonde sur la
condition humaine sur la vie la mort il
ya six épisodes que mahler a tiré d'une
poésie du viiie siècle par libao élan la
conjoncture est très rigolote parce que
jean marie le clézio vient de faire un
livre sur la poésie du viiie siècle et
se lie bao pourrait être une sorte de
verlaine de l'époque la jeunesse la
l'ivresse les jeunes filles en fleur et
puis évidemment l'adieu l'adieu avec en
même temps un message d'espérance et une
constatation de la fatalité inexorable
alors on en rit et coûtera un certain
nombre d'ex trait à la discrétion de
notre réalisateur qui a qui a fait un
choix assez assez précis cet
enregistrement que vous avez fait avec
leur caisse nationale de l'île c'est
alors qu'est ce que vous avez fondé et
que vous avez dirigé pendant 40 ans 40
ans de fidélité c'est extraordinaire
saint jacques est un record 40 ans je ne
trompe pas un 40 ans oui oui même un peu
tout petit peu plus oui
écoutez j'ai été sollicité on est parti
de tellement bas parce que j'ai été
sollicité en 1975 par le ministre de la
culture michel guy pour terminer le
contrat d'un orchestre qui devait d'y
disparaître
c'était dans le cadre de la
restructuration de l'eau ou rtf à paris
re centralisation voulue par le
président giscard d'estaing et qui
évidemment plongés dans l'angoissé
retint nombre de un certain nombre de
salariés de deux musiciens donc je suis
parti de rien du tout et puis la
construction a abouti à ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui c'est à dire un magnifique
orchestre
oui un de niveau international parce que
je crois qu'il est connu dans le monde
entier
alors avant de revenir
sur votre votre parcours votre partition
personnelle je voulais vous demander
dans quel état d'esprit vous être parce
que je crois savoir que vous aviez très
récemment en janvier la diriger
c'était à la philharmonie à paris
c'était le 18 janvier si je ne me trompe
pas et la salle était vide
quel effet ça fait de diriger un
orchestre film dans une salle vie mais
écoutez je peux pas vous dire que ce
soit la chose la plus gratifiante du
monde parce que quand vous êtes dans l'
enthousiasme dans la communication de
les mots de l'émotion dans la
transmission et puis voilà le
l'orchestré s'arrête
normalement il ya une énergie qui vient
aussi du public est là l'énergie bah
écoute et on l'a trouvée quand même avec
ces merveilleux musiciens ces jeunes
musiciens du conservatoire de paris et
c'était un superbe programme que
d'ailleurs vous pouvez entendre sur le
site de la philharmonie et c'était une
une sensation assez particulière parce
que la salle est très belle et très
grande il ya 2000 places et il y avait
simplement une trentaine de
professionnels dans la salle donc en
effet c'est surprenant pour ne rien vous
cacher parce que le chef d'orchestre il
dirige et les spectateurs il les a dans
le dos il ne les voit pas mais vous le
sentez les spectateurs en général ah oui
oui il ya des vibrations vous savez dieu
merci tout n'est pas robotisée dans dans
la vie et surtout pour les artistes et
quelque chose de quand même d'organique
qui passe entre la scène la salle
la présence des uns des autres celle du
chef d'orchestre et voilà le public
renvoie quelque chose de d'irrationnel
mais qui nous qui nous porte et qui nous
porte aussi à lui renvoyer la somme des
émotions qu'on veut partager
donc ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui depuis
presque un an
on est privé de deux de ce lien social
la musique c'est quand même l'un des
meilleurs liens sociaux ce qui assure le
lien sera oui non mais alors vous avez
oui non mais alors là je suis d'accord
avec vous est alors je trouve je suis un
tout petit peu triste de constater que
on ne fait pas confiance je dirais à la
prudence des professionnels parce que
quand vous voyez bon bah on va pas
revenir là dessus tout le monde en a
parlé mais les grands magasins le métro
les trains les aéroports
archi bourré et que dans notre métier on
a eu je crois à l'intelligence de
respecter les distances les cinémas
pourrait en effet continuer de marcher
les salles de concert les salles de
théâtre et les danseurs parce que sous
les la chose la plus difficile du monde
pour des artistes qui travaillent
toujours en anticipation c'est de
répéter pendant des heures pendant des
jours et puis tout d'un coup du jour au
lendemain
voilà ils sont malheureusement flag et
si j'ose dire en plein vol et et ça
n'est pas totalement légitime dans la
mesure où on peut on peut contrôler la
sécurité on peut surveiller
voilà je me mets à la place de voilà de
tous ces gens qui subissent pas
seulement dans les cultures évidemment
mais qui subissent les ravages de de
cette période calamiteuse
mais pour en rester au niveau des
musiciens que vous connaissez comment
est-ce qu'on peut garder le moral dans
une situation pareille alors celle de
sommes habitués à la concentration à
cultiver la vie intérieure et je crois
que cela donne un bon entraînement pour
faire face à des épreuves et la musique
si on arrive à en jouer un peu savent
outre ensemble s'avoue ravi c'est une
planète magique c'est une prairie dont
les fleurs sont les notes et des
musiciens les jardiniers et on peut si
on a la possibilité de partager nos
émotions qui sont nôtres humus
alors voilà le roi n'est pas notre
cousin ça s'adresse à l'imaginaire la
musique et si on a un bon imaginaire on
peut en effet être ravis c'est à dire
être arrachée à son propre univers
mais vous parvenez vous à la rentrée
dans dance est dans cette situation dans
cette position-là d'introspection parce
que vous n'avez plus votre instrument
votre instrument il ay là il a explosé
il a éclaté vous ne pouvez plus vous
voulez parler d'eux
du confinement ujica de l'impossibilité
de faire ou de la musique
alors oui bon écoutez il ya la lecture
via netflix et puis hier à contre la
concentration sur le futur qu'on espère
un peu plus souriant
je travaille aussi des partitions si
vous voulez des partitions que peut-être
je ne dirigerai pas car évidemment comme
beaucoup d'entre nous j'ai plus d'une
vingtaine de concerts et de programmes
qui ont été annulés alors on va on va
parler du futur et la façon dont vous le
vous le voyez le vous êtes né dans la
musique vous êtes mais dans une famille
d'artistes
votre vote votre mère gisèle casadesus
était bon tout le monde s'en souvient
encore
et tant que comédienne halte à la
comédie-française vos grands-parents et
ému était était musicien mais vous je
crois savoir que vous ne destiniez pas à
la musique
vous vouliez faire sciences po bâton dit
j'envisage de faire sciences po pour
être aussi un grand reporter sur les
points chauds du monde
je voulais aller rendre compte d enfin
voilà des vies parfois perturbé de la
planète
et puis la musique m'a absolument rapt
et parce que le son la volupté du son
que j'ai pu que j'ai pu pénétrer dans
dans les années où j'ai joué du piano et
de l'orgue et puis ils désirent révélée
brutalement par si vous voulez ma prime
à la prise de conscience du concert
symphonique qui m'a donné envie d'être
chef d'orchestre ça a balayé tout le
reste voilà mai
je je crois que dans mon métier je peux
aussi comme si j'avais été reporter je
peux aussi témoigner comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure du lien
fédéraliste de la musique de la
possibilité de partager de grandes
émotions d'améliorer la vie de personnes
qui croient que la grande musique ça
n'est pas pour eux est de donner aussi
au partage de la musique
la fonction sociale qui n'est pas
uniquement celles réservées à je dirais
aux happy few qui font parfois de la
rétention de savoir je crois qu'il faut
partager le bonheur c'est dostoïevski
qui a dit la beauté sauvera le monde
je crois que les artistes peuvent y
contribuer qui est-ce qui vous a mis la
première fois une baguette dans la main
qu'est ce qui vous a mis le j'allais
dire le pied à l'étrier non mais la
baguette dans la main alors la première
baguette ça a été un archet un archet
que mon grand-père avec mon grand père
qui était henri casadesus le fondateur
de la société des instruments anciens
qui a été le premier orchestre baroque
très célèbre au début du 20e siècle
ils ont joué devant toutes les cours
d'europe avec ses frères et ses soeurs
lorsqu'il était le neuvième enfant d'une
famille de 14 et donc son père luis
casadesus qui était catalan adorait la
musique il était musicien amateur il
avait rêvé que ses enfants fassent tous
de la musique et donc mon grand-père me
mais comme j'avais 4 ans et demi dans
les mains avec son ami pierre monteux ce
lieu célèbre chef d'orchestre qui avait
créé le sacre du printemps
il me met un violon dans les mains alors
là je découvre la volupté de produire
des sons ça n'a pas duré très longtemps
parce que j'avais une crampe et là j'ai
abandonné pour le piano et puis ensuite
j'ai découvert à 11 ans et demi à 12 ans
j'ai découvert l'orchestré symphonique
ceux des murs
il descendit déchaîné des tonnerres ou
qui calmait les tempêtes et j'ai eu la
révélation comme comme saint paul
terrasse est sur le chemin de la foi
la révélation de mon désir d'être chef
d'orchestre que je n'ai pu réaliser
évidemment qu'à l'âge de 30 ans on a dit
parfois d'un certain nombre de vos
confrères que la direction d'orchestre
c'est une manifestation du pouvoir
c'était le goût du pouvoir faire ronfler
un orchestre crois que c'est une
expression que qui est utilisée parfois
c est ce qu est ce que vous étiez mû par
ce moteur l'art de cette ambition-là de
diriger il ya ya ya une autorité
derrière le chef d'orchestre
obligatoires or alors il ya une
possibilité de choix et il ya la
nécessité de transmettre une conception
mais vous savez de la même façon que le
mot ministre c'est servir le mou chef
d'orchestre c'est d'abord servir s'est
d'abord essayé de respecter et la
musique et les collègues qui ont une
fonction qui sont les musiciens ses
collègues et ses jeans
j'ai plusieurs devises mais j'en ai une
entre autres qui est servie rose et
transmettre et obtenir servir s'être
vraiment essayé de se glisser dans la
pensée du compositeur et essayer de
traduire sa pensée de la même façon que
geppetto anime pinocchio et le
chef-d'oeuvre geppetto c'est celui qui
anime au sens au sens latin du terme aux
essais s'autoriser quelques
transgression qu'on croit positive une
couleur un tempo un silence habité mais
toujours en respectant le texte
transmettre la musique nous transmet à
nous chefs d'orchestre de la
transmettons aux musiciens nous la
transmettrons au public est la chose la
plus difficile c'est obtenir obtenir le
résultat de la conception indispensables
pour aborder une oeuvre sans se laisser
entraîner ni à droite ni à gauche comme
pourrait le faire un cheval
il voudrait aller brouter alors en ce
sens en en oubliant le chemin qu'il doit
suivre donc si vous voulez la relation
de pouvoir c'est vraiment non c'est pour
moi c'est du folklore on a un pouvoir
on peut pas voter pour savoir quel tempo
on va prendre
en effet on décide mais on décide en
fonction du service que l'on doit à la
musique
oui vous savez ce qui est extraordinaire
en vous écoutant mais je veux pas vous
entraîner sur un terrain qui n'est pas
le nôtre là actuellement c'est que vous
donner la définition du management
finalement vous donner la définition
d'une gouvernance à la fois dans
lentreprise com com com comment
politiques quelque part alors peut-être
qu'on va reparler d'eux
l'instant on va s'arrêter quelques
minutes la voilà retour sur le plateau
de la grande interview toujours avec
notre invité jean claude casadesus le
célébrissime chef d'orchestre fondateur
animateur pendant 40 ans de leur caisse
nationale de l'île jean claude casadesus
vous nous parliez avec avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé beaucoup de conviction de
votre envie de faire partager la musique
au plus grand nombre
ce qui m'a frappé en regardant un peu
votre je reparte de votre partition
parce que c'est une vraie partition
votre vie c'est le côté éclectique de de
votre parcours parce que vous avez
évidemment travaillé avec beaucoup d
orchestre symphonique avec beaucoup de
plaisir sur des partitions de wagner
mais hausse tant dans la variété on vous
trouve chez charles aznavour
on vous trouve c'est jacques brel on
vous trouvera chez chez brassens on vous
trouve même chez chela mais quelque part
vous n'avez pas honte d'avoir fait ça ou
fait quelques pas à quoi ça correspond
comment est ce que je pourrais avoir
honte d'une richesse
il m'a permis d'aborder tous les styles
de mon métier mais je me sens minable
mais à la place des amateurs de grande
musique
alors écoutez les amateurs au sens noble
du terme qui veut dire aimer doivent
comprendre qu'est ce que c'est que les
styles les styles c'est l'identification
et leiria de plus riche qu'un éclectisme
éclairé pour aborder en effet tous les
styles
j'étais percussionniste professionnel
j'ai été batteur percussionniste j'ai
joué du piano j'ai joué de l'orgue et
donc comme je suis devenu chef
d'orchestre
j'avais déjà eu la possibilité et sous
la direction de très grands chefs
internationaux mais aussi de
merveilleuses arrangeur de pouvoir
aborder les disques des enregistrements
de jacques brel d'asda bourde de béco de
léo ferré
comme vous venez de le dire mais ça
m'avait ouvert si vous voulez
le voilà le panthéon musical qui me
permettait en effet après d'apprécier et
de comprendre toutes sortes de musiques
ça permet d'élargir le public aussi
d'essayer d'agde de de prendre des
jeunes par la main et de les amener à
une autre forme de musique
le oui bien sûr et puis alors on a le
droit d'aimer le jazz moi j'étais
j'avais un orchestre de jazz à 14 ans
mes petits fils david et thomas enhco
sont des formidables musiciens de jazz
ma fille est chanteuse ma nièce et
chanteuse voilà si vous voulez il ya ya
une espèce de comment je dirais de
creuser dans la famille qui permet en
effet aux uns et aux autres de
comprendre que la richesse c'est la
diversité c'est pas le sectarisme
or il faut sortir des carcans qui ne
vous dirige que vers une seule une seul
à seul style par exemple pour essayer de
comprendre les différentes richesses
la musique de variété le jazz recèle des
richesses absolument magnifique
et puis la musique classique la musique
symphonique aussi simplement ma
spécialité évidemment après toutes ces
années c'est la musique symphonique que
j'ai essayé de transmettre à ceux qui
pensaient que la grande musique comme il
disait n'était pas pour eux et je les
écris dans deux livres où je décris mon
désir de partage oui alors je vous
provoquer un petit peu là pour pour
aller dans le fond de votre tesi alesi
je me aller souviens d'une rencontre
avec vous aux musicales de reims dans
dans des décors qui était sont eux ou
vous aviez diriger le boléro de ravel et
nous étions avec quelques journalistes
un peu hein
un peu sarcastique par rapport au boléro
de ravel qui est quand même une
ritournelle qu'on a tellement entendu
que la question est de savoir mais
comment est-ce qu'on peut encore se
passionner pour un alors vous étiez là
et vous nous avait expliqué pendant une
heure mesure par mesure les secrets du
boléro de ravel et j'ai trouvé ça
franchement extraordinaire
ben vous êtes gentil mais c'est pas une
provocation c'est au contraire une
accélération de mais mais mais mais mais
le boléro de ravel ça a été écrit c'est
une sorte de gadget de la part de ravel
dont auquel il ne croyait pas lui-même
trouvé trouvé que c'était d'une
simplicité
il ya une dame lors de lors d'une d'une
exécution du boléro ou même à la
création
je crois qu'il ya 10 ans fin qu'est ce
que ça veut dire on se moque de moi ça
n'est pas de la musique et ravel qui l'a
entendu lui dis oh oui je suis bien de
votre avis madame alors que c'est
l'oeuvre avec carmen de bizet la plus
joué au monde parce qu'il ya quelque
chose de formidablement organique qu'en
plus chaque musicien de l'orchestré est
sollicité et qui a quelque chose de
viscéral et de charnel dans cette
musique c'est ça que vous nous aviez
expliqué c'est que chaque musicien est
sollicité et que chaque musicien à un
moment donné est une star quoi dans et
se détache du reste de l' orchestre
combien de fois vous avez ces héros de
rafael vous avez exécuté le bread
rappelle combien de fois ont écouté j'ai
pas fait le jeu parfait le compte mais
je sais pas peut-être way cinquantaine
de fois en tout cas au moins et j'en ai
fait aussi un enregistrement
oui je sais et à chaque fois avec
toujours du plaisir toujours du plaisir
savez chaque fois que je me présente
devant un orchestre c'est avec l'idée
que nous allons essayer de créer
ensemble une joie partagée devant ces
chefs-d'oeuvre de la musique qu'on a
l'honneur de servir
c'est toujours une remise en question et
c'est toujours pour moi une fraîcheur
nouvelle à apporter c'est comme j'ai
dirigé au châtelet moquette est mon
premier poste où j'ai dirigé luis
mariano georges guétary jeanrichard
l'auberge du cheval blanc pendant trois
ans je
je suis absolument contre un tous les
soirs à respecter les nuances du début
pour ne surtout pas tomber dans la
routine
or il n'ya pas de routine dans notre
métier quand la passion l'animent
les français aiment la musique
les chiffres le montrent mais les
français ne sont pas musiciens où ils
sont assez peu musicien par rapport aux
allemands ou par rapport aux italiens il
ya un problème d'éducation là il ya un
problème parce que au départ c'est quand
même un peu un peu dur la musique le
solfège et on a tous des souvenirs
compliqué de l'apprentissage du solfège
est ce qu écouter les français sont pas
plus bêtes que d'autres et sont pas
moins insensible mais sont très
rationnels ils sont très tournée vers la
littérature il ya des cartes qui nous a
beaucoup guidée des cartes boileau en
sarre et puis de là la poésie bien sûr
et puis la peinture et la musique qui
est une des plus belles du monde qui est
très clair très élégante très analyser
très analytique n'a pas la folie de la
mittel europa
je pense à wagner je pense h 30 je pense
à mahler évidemment ou à la musique
russe avec tchaïkovski prokofiev
rachmaninov
les français sont peut-être plus comment
dirais-je
il illustre parfaitement bien la réponse
qu'on demandait andré gide un jour en
trois mots en lui disant qu'est ce que
c'est pour vous la définition en trois
mots de du style français de la musique
française à 8 en trois mots écoutez
c'est difficile et il dit rien de trop
et c'est vrai que les français sont
mesurés assez raisonnable crois que la
musique en effet doit passer d'abord par
la théorie mais ça tu changes est
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de je
dirais de transmetteurs à l'art auquel
je m'honore de faire partie essaye de
partager d'abord le plaisir
d'abord la lucide la ludicité auprès des
enfants et après de leur enseigner la
rigueur incontournable pour
l'accomplissement du désir mais dans ce
cas là parce qu'ils en ont envie la
rigueur devient volupté et c'est ça que
je me suis efforcé de transmettre aux
enfants ou quinze mille enfants que
j'avais par an dans mon entreprise avec
leur caisse nationale de l'île entre
autres oui oui comment vous voyez
l'avenir maintenant à 85 ans là je
trouve que comme me disait maman qui est
morte à 103 en mai 10 cents ans s'est
passé si vite je vous dirais que 85 ans
je trouve que c'est passé encore plus
vite que ce que je croyais mais tant que
si j'ose dire tant que la mécanique
intérieur et extérieur fonctionne que le
désir est là je crois que le
vieillissement vient de l'absence de
désir et de l'absence de projet
donc quand maman avait 100 ans elle a
tourné son dernier film et elle me
disait au bout de quelques semaines
elle me disait c'est calme en ce moment
je souhaite que ça ne soit pas calme en
tout cas non plus pour moi trop
longtemps parce que je me réalise
totalement dans si vous voulez la
transmission dans le partage mais la
musique c'est un moteur un moteur
affectif absolument irremplaçables
est-ce que les technologies nouvelles du
digital notamment du stress vous parliez
du streaming tout à l'heure change
quelque chose à l'exercice de votre
métier
est ce que vous considérez comme
beaucoup de personnes de cette
génération que c'était mieux avant ou
pas ah non non non mais je crois que
l'évolution doit contribuer à la qualité
mais il doit pas contribuer à la
robotisation des âmes ce qui moi me gêne
beaucoup dans l'excès des réseaux
sociaux où l'excès de la technologie où
l'excès des visioconférences c'est où
l'excès des des téléphones vous entendez
halo tapez 1 tapez 2 tapez 3 rappelé et
l'absence d'humanité
or l'art et les artistes sont avant tout
porteur d'une parole d'amour qui passe
par l'affect alors la technologie peut
être un apport contre la création la
craie
évitez charnelle est toujours derrière
ou même je dirais même devant mais il
faut pas qu'on soit esclaves de la
machine
en tout cas pas pour les artistes c'est
un acte d'amour la musique pour vous
c'est un exercice d'avoir 8 mai oui mais
là l'art en général vous savez ça permet
de mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager ça permet de répondre à des
questionnements
c'est la part d'humanité incontournable
et indispensable à l'évolution de tout
être humain je voulais vous poser une
question affreuse épouvantable et
question est pour vous les trois
musiciens les trois compositeurs pardon
hein qui qui vous impressionne le plus
dans l'histoire de la musique
ceux pour qui vous avez une infinie
tendresse et une infinie admiration ce
grâce à qui d'autres génies ont pu
naître pour il ya d'abord pour moi jean
sébastien bach qui a été ma première
passion musicale mozart ensuite
beethoven payton pour moi si vous voulez
mozart c'est la grâce jean sébastien
bach c'est l'architecte qui chante
bétonne pour moi c'est le premier au
coeur du 19e siècle
lemonnier voilà le premier type qui
groove à le broker écouter quand vous
entendez pata pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata papa papa pata pata
vous avez envie de faire ça va aller il
faut que leur qu'istres groove et alors
elle faisait wagner avec sa folie
et puis tous les autres qui sont les
héritiers berlioz évidemment au premier
rang c'est le cas au lit chez des
créateurs
il faut qu'un orchestre groove c'est ça
revient en permanence dans dans vos
écrits dans vos interviews dans ce que
vous dites mais écouter la musique c'est
la traduction la plus poétique de la vie
si vous mettez pas la vie des vides à
mon sens bête si vous ne jouez que les
notes
il faut sortir les notes de leurs
univers carcéral et il faut que les
notes vives et il faut jouer ce qui a
entre les notes et avant tout c'est le
rythme et la pulsation et ça c'est
fondamental pour entraîner et l'
enthousiasme des musiciens et celui du
public
oui alors jean claude casadesus on a
épuisé le temps qui nous étaient pas
partie comme on dit j'aurais voulu
passer des extraits de votre de votre
disque le chant de la terre que vous
avez enregistré à mais on peut le
trouver il est il et l'istat vrai disque
un vrai cd mais on ne peut l'entendre
aussi sur toutes les plateformes
musicales en streaming
vraisemblablement on va d'ailleurs agen
évidence ouais vous reconnaissez ça je
vais vous dire au revoir sur ses notes
l'a22 de musique
je veux vous remercier énormément que du
temps plus ans passés ensemble j'espère
que pour le téléspectateur ce fut aussi
plaisant et aussi puissant que que pour
nous dans le dans le studio merci
beaucoup à bientôt
je sais que vous allez en tournée que
vous avez des dates prévues vous partez
à moscou vous partez à saint pétersbourg
vous devez aller à tokyo vous devez
aller à riga je crois j'espère que le
virus vous laissera partir et que le
virus vous laissera continuer de
d'exécuter des oeuvres avec des
orchestres symphoniques
merci mille fois c'est très gentil merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup jean claude
casadesus cette émission est hélas
terminée vous la retrouvez en replay
vous la retrouvez en rediffusion vous la
retrouver sur tous les réseaux sociaux
vous la retrouvez aussi sur le site
internet bien sûr de rt france et arte
france poi poi tv merci mille fois
à très bientôt
[Musique]
m
i